the near post reports on havoc at Penn
Station after another train derailment
about a hundred and eighty people were
on the train when it left the tracks now
it was the third derailment since March
the country's busiest train station more
than 650,000 people and more than 1300
trains passed through Penn Station each
day annual ridership exceeds 10 million
starting Monday Amtrak will spend about
two months replacing a key section of
the track in parts of the crucial
transit hub will be shut down Kris Van
Cleave is at Penn Station where the
repairs are behind what's being called
the summer of hell Chris good morning
good morning it's what commuters have
been dreading we're talking about tracks
being closed trains being canceled and
rerouted and you may be wondering why do
it during tourist season well Amtrak
says while there's no good time to do it
the summer is actually a little bit
slower than the rest of the year after
three derailments long delays commuter
chaos and even a raw sewage leak Penn
Station is about to begin a crucial
renewal project on this section of track
known as a interlocking when this work
is done will things work the way they're
supposed to things will be much improved
we have more renewal work to carry out I
would tell you we're dealing with the
most critical part of the station right
now
what Mormon is Amtrak CEO it's the
single worst place I've ever seen in
terms of degree of difficulty to do this
kind of work the track works
extraordinarily complex trains are
running around you 24/7 crews have
already started to work but to finish it
three to five of the station's 21 tracks
have to be shut down until September
first
forcing Amtrak to cancel three daily
trains to and from Washington and
reroute several others some through
Grand Central located on the other side
of town for New York area commuters the
track work may force many to use their
cars as an alternative drivers using the
bridges and tunnels already endure
delays in and out of the city it's gonna
be hammer time we've heard the phrase
carpocalypse before to describe
situations of excess traffic due to
whatever reason I think that term could
be a
what we're going to be seeing in the
next four to six weeks the problems
plugging the aging station come as
crucial infrastructure projects to
replace aging bridges and build
additional tunnels have stalled until
those long-term projects are realized
2017 Summer of hell could last longer
than expected is it fair to say this
sort of snuck up on you it certainly
feels like it snuck up on the commuters
it felt like that but I think what you
really were just seeing was the fact
that as the assets continued to age as
we continued to more run more trains
over them they were just reaching a
point of criticality and the time came
for what I think is the appropriate but
more decisive action to restore the
station to where it should be New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie is calling for a
full investigation of this latest
arraignment involving a New Jersey
Transit train here at Penn Station he
and Governor Cuomo of New York have
openly questioned if Amtrak should even
be left in charge of the construction
work and Governor Cuomo has even asked
President Trump to declare this an
emergency to free up additional funds
Jeff Chris Van Cleve thank you very much
it's gonna be very interesting to see
what Richard Anderson the new newly in
charge of Amtrak now who ran Delta Force
along and took it to the biggest airline
in the country is able to do with Amtrak
it seems like there's nowhere to go it
off
I say fix it get it done during the
summer bit and everyone just be kinder
and gentler with everyone that's all so
it's a summer ball whole thing so it's
the summer of nice that's right the
summer of nice the summer palace summers
nice says gale can you go there you go